Show me the one whose safety
deemed such destruction
you must reunite it with its own kind
Where? This you must determine.
the songs of eon's past tell of battles
between mandalore the great and an order
of sorcerers called
jedi
you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy sorcerers?
this is the way
you know this is no place for a child
wherever I go he goes
So I've heard
this is the way
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the
mandalorian season 2 trailer
this is the way so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs so we'll break it all down
the episodes will start dropping on
october 30th as they say during the
trailer of course i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes during
season 2 just like i did for season
one
so we'll go through the trailer shot by
shot talk about the easter eggs and then
i'll talk about the stuff that they did
not put in the trailer but that we know
is happening during season 2 because
there's a lot of stuff that they left
out of this
obviously but they open with a shot of
the razor crest limping past this planet
on its way to another
water-based planet with a cargo hole
jammed open in the vacuum of space with
a tunnel battle damage looking like
they're just barely escaping whatever
encounter they just had
they start with a voiceover from the
armor at the end of season one which
crosses over pretty much the entire
trailer there's very little dialogue
from season 2
in the actual trailer just from that
fight scene at the very end of the
trailer
but she talks about reuniting baby yoda
with his own kind and he talks about the
jedi as a race of ancient sorcerers
you get that cool music cue from ludwin
goranson that's part of the season 2
music if you like the season 1 music
obviously it's going to be off the chain
during season 2.
then you see mando and baby yoda with
his new carrier pod that they made for
him at the end of season one walking
through the night to another town you
can't see what kind of aliens there are
here standing in the street just because
it's so dark but you see some eyes flash
red like jawa's eyes
then when he asks where his kind are
where the jedi are she says this you
must determine and the razor crest flies
over tatooine again which is a nice
easter egg because
luke skywalker anakin skywalker obi-wan
kenobi all
lived on tatooine all jedi you know it's
tatooine because the tuscan raider
riding on his bantha there are a bunch
of
scenes in the trailer on tatooine this
is another scene of them though on a
different ice planet that we've never
been to before giving you hoth vibes
like earlier when john favreau was
talking about the season 2 episodes he
referenced empire strikes back
the sequel to season one so obviously
we're going to be traveling to a
hoth-like planet but this doesn't
confirm that it's going to be hoth it's
probably some other planet
she talks about the songs of eon's past
telling of mandalore's great battles
with the jedi as
mando bends down to talk to baby yoda in
the snow who might be seeing it for the
first time
it's hard to tell where he's been before
he's supposed to be 50 years old so we
don't know how long he was with his
original parents before he was separated
from them
if they're still alive but they probably
lived on a swamp planet because that's
where his kind mostly thrives
so we might actually be seeing snow for
the very first time
then the water planet that the
mandalorian is walking through with his
jet pack there
might actually be mon cala because of
all the quarren
standing in this port we've never
actually been there before in the
live-action movies
when the armor says the word jedi though
you see this hooded figure
seemingly part of the jedi that's kind
of what they're trying to apply by the
trailer then disappear but it could just
be one of the agents or other people
that are looking for him like moff
gideon's people
there's also the idea that around this
period in galactic history there weren't
really a lot of jedi there were a lot of
people that survived the purge who were
force sensitive or people that were
partially trained as jedi but then
didn't complete that training
so they could be referring to a lot of
those people when they're talking about
quote-unquote jedi
the closest thing that we know to actual
jedi showing up during season 2 would
be ahsoka and she's technically not a
jedi anymore she left the order so she's
a former
jedi then you see them on the boat on
that same water planet traveling
somewhere
it sounds like they use that special
volume where they create different
environments just to see what they could
do
more over season one like what did we
not try during season one that we can
try during season 2 well we got ice
planets well we got water planets
this is the razor crest encountering a
squadron of x-wings
like i said empire strikes back
references doesn't this make you think
of the cloud city encounter when they
were going to cloud city and the two
ships rose up next to them in the clouds
i'm guessing that whatever they're doing
in this scene here they're just
encountering the new republic we saw
them a little bit during season one
now it seems like we'll get more
backstory in what's going on with them
during season 2
this seems like them traveling on
speeder bike through the tatooine desert
this is the first look at cara dune and
grief karga back on navarro
then this scene obviously of more thai
outlanders the special thai fighters
with the bendable wings that you saw at
the end of season one that maf gideon
was using
looks like it's happening on navarro
again too these obviously would be
more of moff gideon's forces then this
is probably just another bunch of his
stormtroopers on what's probably one of
his imperial star destroyers or maybe
the only one that he has it's hard to
tell how many forces and which ships
that he has
but giancarlo esposito did imply that he
had a quote unquote
larger ship he referred to in a very
funny way making it sound like it was a
really
really big ship like an imperial star
destroyer it's hard to tell where this
speeder bike chase is happening it could
also be happening on tatooine it could
be happening somewhere else with this
patrol of scout troopers
but then you see mando during this same
chase scene separately using his jet
pack to go after them
this is him in a cage stuck underwater
trying to escape
then they queue up the big fight scene
with the whistling birds again with them
at that fighting ring with that funny
mic drop moment
it's a couple of gamoreans fighting in a
ring with a bunch of other aliens
looking like it's just some sort of
giant casino with a lot of betting going
on in the background
i can't tell which celebrity guest is
voicing this
alien here who's saying you know this is
no place for a child
but i'm guessing that it is one of the
surprise celebrity cameos there's always
a bunch of weird celebrities and star
wars fans from hollywood that show up in
the background as minor aliens
it just seems like this is meant to
reveal a bunch of other bounty hunters
that are trying to take baby yoda from
him so i'm assuming that moff gideon has
also taken out more bounties on baby
yoda so he'll be chasing them off left
and right while he's busy trying to find
the jedi
they have that funny moment where he
activates the whistling birds and baby
yoda
looks down at it instantly remembers
what happened during season one when he
saved him with the whistling birds
hits the close hatch button because he
knows what's about to happen
yoink
then they cut to the scene after with
him taking the rest of them down
with his knife saying this is the way
ending the trailer
but there's a couple other scenes they
cut into this big montage this is him
interrogating someone using the
grappling hook on that town from before
he reiterates baby yoda goes where i go
and then obviously there's a bunch of
stuff that we know about during season
two that did not appear during this
trailer so you didn't see any kind of
ahsoka
at least that we know about she could be
hiding in the background of one of these
shots and they just digitally remove her
or they haven't added her in yet
you have to remember that a lot of this
is happening on a blue screen or with
big led panels in the background and
they just fill it in with digital
characters and digital backgrounds
so they can remove or hide anything that
they don't want you to see in any of
this trailer footage
little bum that we didn't see any of
moff gideon using the dark saber that's
probably going to be in one of the next
trailers this is really just meant to be
the first big teaser trailer so don't
worry there will be more footage that
they'll release before season 2 starts
there's all the boba fett stuff and the
temura morrison that they've teased
before we don't really know exactly what
he's going to be doing during season 2
but
it's implied that it's going to be a
very empire strikes back type of story
if those are the references they're
going for
they said a lot of the season 1
references were mostly built on the
first act
just the first act from star wars
episode 4 a new hope
so john favreau just spent a lot of time
talking about empire strikes back
those references in season 2 episodes
so when you're thinking about
what they might be referencing just
think of what happened during empire
strikes back
they also confirmed that the story of
the episodes will be a little more
serialized like the season one episodes
were kind of a bunch of different
one-offs strung together with a very
loose plot just a few
connected characters appearing in
multiple episodes it'll be a little bit
different during season 2
the entertainment weekly article that
they published with the preview for the
show
referenced katee sackhoff's Bo Katan Kryze
showing up in live action they
didn't say whether or not she's going to
show up in present day or if it'll be in
flashbacks
because the last time that we saw boca
tan was right before the events of the
original trilogy
so this is obviously happening five
years plus after the end of return of
the jedi so a lot of time has passed we
don't really know what happened to her
during the original trilogy
we also don't know how maf gideon got
the darksaber although it's implied that
he got it from her
either killed her to take it or just
stole it from her
michael bain is also playing a new
character but we don't know who he's
playing it just implied that he's going
to be another older bounty hunter but
like we saw a bunch of bounty hunters
show up to take baby yoda fernando
during the trailer it'll probably be
like that through a lot of the episodes
the quote from john favreau also says
the new season is about introducing a
larger story
in the world so he's talking about
galactic story when you think star wars
you think the big movies you think about
the scope of the story and how big it
gets
season one was largely self-contained
just because they weren't quite sure
what they could do
and how to work with the technology for
filming the episodes since
season one wound up being such a banger
they did so well they just went
way more epic with season 2 dave
filoni's quote is also really cool too
he says everything gets bigger the
stakes get higher but also the personal
story between the child
and the mandalorian develops in a way
that i think people will enjoy
so i think they're just leaning on the
whole father-child aspect of it
the armorer kind of tells him that at
the end of season one you are now a clan
of two as he gets his new crest that's
based on the mudhorn that baby yoda
helped him defeat and saved him from
so he really will be kind of like his
father during season 2
but if you're hoping for a bunch of epic
lightsaber fights with moth giddy and
the darksaber giancarlo esposito has
been going on and on about the crazy
fights that he has
with the dark saber but i'm assuming
that those are really complicated and
there's a lot of special effects and
they're saving those for like the last
couple of trailers
we could talk about it all day but
everybody just let me know what your
favorite moments from the trailer are if
you spotted any big easter eggs that i
didn't mention in the video and of
course i'll just keep doing more
mandalorian season 2 videos as we get
new information and new footage
once we get within a few weeks of the
episodes coming they'll drop way more
footage
so baby yoda and the mandalorian are
here to save your 2020 from being
complete crap
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when they post
you can click here for all my
mandalorian season 2 and season 1
episode videos and you can click here
for the really big new marvel avengers
movies announcement and brand new
villain that they're introducing to the
mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way!